hello everyone oh today we are going to
talk about Quantum algorithms and the
power of forgetting
um I am ameen Shah gadani and this is
Joint work with Andrew Charles and
medical drone so let's get started
um we begin with the scenario we are
interested in
um let PB any black box problem that
exhibits exponential Quantum advantage
that is there is a query efficient
Quantum algorithm for B but no query
efficient classical algorithm
and there is a small classical proof
that certifies the correctness of the
solution for p
the question that we are motivated by is
as follows
does there exist a problem P that
satisfies these conditions but there is
no efficient Quantum query algorithm
that outputs some small classical proof
of its solution
which we now exist because P satisfies
the last condition over here
foreign let us look at some candidates
for such a problem
so can t be the hidden subgroup problem
even though the above conditions are
satisfied there is an efficient Quantum
query algorithm
that finds assessing description of the
Hidden subgroup
so P can be the hidden subgroup problem
can t be the correlation problem
correlation does not satisfy the last
condition
uh namely there is no
small classical proof of its solution
can t be the value tree exit finding
problem
maybe let's find out
for those not aware of this problem we
will go through it now
let's begin by describing the value tree
graph
um it is simply a mage with a special
entrance and exit vertices
which is formed by joining two
um balanced binary trees of heightened
such that the leaves of these trees here
form a 2 to the N plus 1 vertex cycle
and each leaf on the left is joined to
two
um leaves on the right and vice versa
we call any Leaf of the binary trees
joined to form a welded tree graph a
weld vertex so any of these vertices
here is what we denote by a value vertex
and the cycle joining the world well
vertices the well cycle so this big
cycle over here uh will denote it by a
well cycle
you will need to describe colorings and
labelings of this graph in order to
precisely Define a problem
notice that a value tree is a bipartite
graph with degree atmosphere so it can
be H colored using three colors
we will assume that it is Edge colored
using colors red green and blue
um we label each vertex by a two two and
length bit string
the reason to do this is to ensure that
it is exponentially unlikely for any
algorithm to guess any valid vertex
label in this graph
we will be given auricular access to
this graph
um a validatory Oracle is described by
three functions specified by colors red
blue and green
where for instance the red function
takes is input of vertex V and outputs
the neighbor of e with red Ash color
yeah
we are now ready to define the value
tree exit binding problem
we are given the
Oracle we described in the last slide
and the label of the entrance vertex and
the goal is to find the label of the
exit what x
child's at all found a query efficient
Quantum walk algorithm for this problem
and they also showed that no classical
query efficient algorithm can find the
exit
we would also like to mention
that this classical hardness result is
called the colorless Oracle so it is not
directly imply an analogous result for
the three colored article
um because a valid three color three
coloring might enforce Global
correlations in our literary graph
um which could possibly be used by some
algorithm to find the exit efficiently
recently this problem was shown to be
hard even for poly log depth Quantum
circuits interleaved with polynomial
size classical computations
um a consequence of this is an auricular
separation between bqb and the class of
problems solvable by poly log depth
column circuits
let us form a concrete connection
between the value tree exit finding
problem and there are motivational
question that we started with
um clearly an entrance to exit Parts in
the welded tree graph is a classical
proof of the correctness of the label of
the exit
but so does the degree of the exit
vertex since it is the only vertex apart
from the entrance with degree 2 in the
valedictory graph
however the degree argument fails to
work for the following variant of the
weld tree exit finding problem
um a modified valuatory graph is a graph
that consists of two copies of a valid
tree
with the entrance of the first copy
joined with the entrance of the second
copy and the exit of the first copy
joined with the exit of the second copy
the corresponding exit finding problem
which we call the modified welded tree
exit finding is as follows
we are given an oracle for the mod for
the modified welded tree graph and the
labels of the two entrance vertices and
the two exit vertices and the goal is to
find the correct matching of the
entrance vertices with the exit vertices
so one can formally verify that only an
even length path from an entrance vertex
to an exit vertex is a classical proof
of the correct matching
this gives rise to the welded tree
pathfinding problem so let us look at
what it is
[Music]
in the valley tree pathfinding problem
the inputs are the same
um
those for the value tree exit finding
problem uh namely you are given a value
tree Oracle and the label of the
entrance vertex and the goal as you
might imagine is to find an entrance to
exit path
from a classical intuition these
problems seem essentially the same
it might be possible to guess a Vertex
labeled close to exit that is very
unlikely in other words if you want to
find the exit classically you will need
to Traverse a path to the exit
let us consider a naive Quantum strategy
um take the quantum walk algorithm of
child at all and make measurements after
each step of this algorithm
but making such measurements will
destroy the superpositions which would
constructively interfere later on to get
to the exit so this tweaked algorithm
will not be able to find the exit let
alone a path to the exit
rizman is considered this pathfinding
problem and he gave what he called a
quorum snake walk algorithm but he did
not prove its query complexity
the community however believes that the
query complexity of his algorithm is
exponential
erinson mentioned this problem as one of
the major open problems in Quorum query
complexity in his recent article
we now State our main result
which is that there is no efficient
genuine rooted Quantum query algorithm
for the welded tree pathfinding problem
we have not talked about General
algorithms and looted algorithms yet but
we will do that next
informally an algorithm for pathfinding
is genuine if it only provides
meaningful vertex labels to the welded
tree Oracle
classically genuineness is easy to
Define we simply disallow any algorithm
to feed in any vertex label that it has
not seen
it is not so straightforward Quantum
beta we do this by exhaustively defining
a git set that we believe satisfies the
genuine property let's look at some
examples of these Gates
an obvious one is the query gate which
takes a Vertex label
and an insular vertex adjuster as input
and computes the seat neighbor of the
input vertex in the Ancilla register
another genuine gate is the partial swap
operator
the gate this gate is crucial used in
the exit finding algorithm of charge at
all
it takes two vertex labels as input and
outputs a particular superposition of
these labels
uh being in place or them being swapped
full definition of genuine algorithms
includes other Gates that generalize
these examples
we note that the exit finding algorithm
and the pathfinding algorithm that we
stated above are generally algorithms
the formally State what we mean by
rooted algorithm
we say that an algorithm is rooted if it
always maintains at least one path from
the entrance to every vertex appearing
in its state
that is for every vertex that it has
seen it knows a path from the entrance
to that vertex
this means that finding the exit will be
sufficient to find a path to the exit
because we always remember a path to the
entrance
we make this assumption because we
believe that it is natural to remember a
path to the entrance since the goal is
to eventually compute an entrance to
exit path
of course our result is not rule out the
existence of an efficient non-rooted
algorithm for path binding and it would
be very interesting to figure out if
that is actually the case
we now give an overview of our proof
given any genuine rooted Quantum
algorithm we construct a non-adaptive
classical algorithm
that simulates the given algorithm with
a polynomial overhead in the number of
queries
then we show that any non-adaptive
classical algorithm for a three colored
voluntary Oracle cannot find the exit or
a cycle with more than exponentially
small probability
um it is easy to see that points one and
two imply the required required hardness
result
um we will give a little bit more
intuition on Arguments for points one
and two
um starting with the notion of addresses
an address is basically a sequence of
colors
um we say that a sequence of colors is
an address for vertex V in the valid
tree graph if we start at the entrance
and follow the Edge Edge colors given by
the sequence then we end up reaching the
vertex V
foreign
address is associated with one vertex
that is the vertex that it ends up
reaching but each vertex will have many
addresses
we now describe the notion of an address
tree
and address tree
is like a binary tree its root is a
vertex labeled empty address
which will be associated with the
entrance vertex in the valley tree graph
on this component here
um which is connected to the root by a
directed Edge
um is here to handle boundary cases such
as querying the non-existing neighbor of
the entrance in the valley tree graph
for each Edge color incident to the
address we draw industry and undirected
Edge incentive incident to the root of
that color
um remember that in the example we
showed the entrance had a red edge and a
blue edge incident to it so here we have
a red and the blue undirected edge
incident to the root
um
each known root and non-leaf vertex have
three outgoing edges one of each color
so for instance this vertex
as an edge of each color incident to it
um each known vertex on the left
and side of the tree
is labeled by the sequence of colors
that you can take from the root to reach
that vertex so for instance the vertex
labeled by R gamma G indicates that it
is the green neighbor of the red
neighbor of the root
um the address 3 article is also
specified by three functions like the
valedictory Oracle uh one for each color
so so for instance the red function
takes an address as an input and outputs
its neighbors industry with red Edge
color
um notice that the only degree of
freedom
in specifying the dress tree is in the
colors of the undirected edges to the
root
which depends on the colors of the edges
incident to the entrance in the weld
tree graph
now this information can be obtained by
making two queries to the welded tree
Oracle
once and and once these edges are fixed
the rest of the dress tree can be
constructed without making any queries
to the value tree article
um let us describe our classical
simulation algorithm yeah
we begin with the initial state that has
stored empty address in one of its
registers
along with polynomially many nclr
registers that can store addresses of
polynomial length
we also allow for some additional
workspace
then we simulate the given genuine
rooted algorithm
with the welded tree Oracle replaced by
the address tree Oracle
next we measure all the address
registers of the final State Phi of the
above simulation
um which correspond to these registers
over here
then we query the welded tree Oracle for
the vertices
associated with the addresses that we
received in the last step
and finally we output the resulting
vertex labels that we got in step four
so let us analyze the query complexity
of this algorithm
uh note that only steps two and four
require querying the given valid tree
Oracle
we noted in the last slide that the
address tree Oracle can be constructed
with only two queries to the valid tree
Oracle so we can simulate the Second
Step using only two queries
since the number of addresses
and the length
um
of
of each address that we measured in step
three is polynomial
the number of queries we make in step
four is a polynomial times a polynomial
which is still a polynomial
this is a query complexity of our
classical simulation is polynomial
foreign
you might wonder why does this algorithm
work
um let us use PSI to denote the final
state of the given genuine rooted
algorithm and recall that Phi is this
minus state of our classical simulation
we show that our algorithm exactly
simulates the component of PSI and that
does not contain the exit or a cycle
this is because the vertices stored in
any basis state in the support of
this component of PSI
will have a one-to-one correspondence
with the address is stored in the
corresponding basis state of Phi
we also showed that the component of Phi
containing the exit or a cycle is
exponentially small
um using the classical hardness result
for the three colored Oracle which we
will discuss in a moment
and finally since PSI and Phi are valid
Quantum States they're normalized so we
have the final state of our classical
simulation very close to the final state
of the given genuine rooted algorithm
um definitely this argument is over is
already simplified and does not cover
many cases for instance an algorithm
could compute a cycle and uh um and
uncomputed later and pretend to have
never computed it
we cannot detect that using this
algorithm but we can extend the ideas we
presented here to handle such issues
let's now discuss some intuition behind
our classical harness result
um consider any classical algorithm
that follow a fixed polynomial length
color sequence with no even palindromes
that is um it is not backtrack
I guess to the classical hardness result
of childs at all we show that it is hard
to go back to the entrance or get close
to the exit after reaching the well
cycle
so once we are here
it is hard to go too far either way
foreign we also show that it is
improbable to encounter two well
vertices that are connected by at least
two short paths
a key ingredient in our analysis is what
we call a color preserving permutation
um we say that any well vertex is a c
left vertex if it is joined to the left
binary tree with an edge of C color
so for instance these two vertices over
here are red left vertices
um
a color preserving permutation is
defined to be a permutation of the well
vertices such that c left vertices are
mapped to see left vertices and C right
vertices are mapped to C right vertices
for all C and the well neighbors of a
well vertex are permuted according to
this permutation
it is easy to check that color
preserving permutations Maps value trees
through all the trees an example of a
color preserving swap is shown here
uh if we swap these two vertices in this
value tree
we get the value Tree on the right which
is the same as the validity on the left
except for the well neighbors of these
two vertices swapped
so in this case this vertex is connected
to these two vertices over here but uh
in this valid tree uh the
um this vertex is connected to these two
vertices
we conclude this talk by reviewing our
main result based on our findings if
there is an efficient Quantum algorithm
for welded tree pathfinding then it must
use vertex labels in a critical way or
it must forget the entrance before
finding it later along with a path to
the exit
um there is any such algorithm must be
not genuine or not rooted not in our
terminology
[Music]
our work leaves the phoning problems
open
the first and the most natural open
problem is to generalize the results
about the hardness of pathfinding for
efficient genuine rooted Quantum
algorithms to all efficient Quantum
algorithms
or alternatively find efficient Quantum
query algorithm for pathfinding
um
and easier open problem is to generalize
our results about the hardness of exit
finding in that c colored setting for
efficient non-adaptive classical
algorithms to all efficient classical
algorithms or alternatively find an
efficient classical query algorithm for
exit finding in the setting
these are the references that we use in
our dock thank you for listening